[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مو عيب اننا نطيح العيب اللي نبقى يا ولد
نازل الشنطه
مرحبا اعمال سعوديه عديده تتنافس في
الموسم الرمضاني الحالي معظم هذه الاعمال
يدور في فلك الكوميديا بينما طبعا لا زالت
الدراما الجاده غائبه قليلا حيث يوجد ما
يقارب سته اعمال كوميديه في مواجهه 3
اعمال اجراميه انسانيه واجتماعيه طبعا هذه
الاعمال هي طاش ما طاش بجزء التاسع عشر من
ولدنا بجزء الثاني سكه سفر بجزء الثاني
شباب البومب بودكاست واستديو ثلاثه
شهر رمضان طبعا اعتدنا نشاهد المسلسلات
والبرامج الكوميديه بكثره طبعا المشاهد هو
مستسلم من هذا الموضوع يعني صاروا المنتج
او صارت صار المسؤولين عن الحركه الفنيه
في السعوديه يعتمدون ان الكوميديه تكون
بشكل طاغي في شهر رمضان والتصق هذا الشيء
للسنين طويله مع العلم انه عندنا الكوادر
وعندنا الفنانين وعندنا المنتجين وعندنا
حتى يعني الافكار اللي من الممكن تكون
يعني بشكل كبير تغطي الدراما عندنا في
رمضان
[موسيقى]
يمكن ما ربيتكم وعلمتكم الادب
ورغم انه عدد الاعمال الكوميديه في تراجع
كبير بمصر الا انه في السعوديه لا زالت
الصداره للكوميديا وبحسب الاحصاءات يعد
رمضان والموسم الاكثر جذبا للانتاجات
الكوميديه بينما يغلب الطابع الدرامي
الاجتماعي الجاد على الاعمال المحليه طوال
العام وخاصه على المنصات حيث توقف
المنتجين هناك عن البحث عن الكوميديا
اليوم نحن نعيش فتره ذهبيه من خلال الدعم
من خلال تعدد القنوات عدد المنصه
اللهف والشغف
الجماهير لهذا الانتاج ايضا لابد ان يكون
عند انتاج متنوع لجمهور رايه بالتاكيد ما
بين الكوميديا واشكال الدراما الاخرى
وخاصه فيما يخص الانتاجات السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اليوم ما راح تحصله بالغرام
ما شاء الله عليك صدق
دايما احب الازرع البسمه امام الكاميرا
معروف انا بعفاوي عفويه